et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Bruno Retailleau bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sénateurs de vente et
président du groupe les républicains ici
au Sénat on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview avec la
presse régionale représentée par Julien
Lecuyer de la Voix du Nord bonjour
Julien bonjour Oriane bonjour monsieur
constitutionnel n'a donc pas validé la
demande de référendum qui avait été
déposée par les sénateurs de gauche
est-ce que consulter les Français
n'auraient pas été la meilleure manière
de sortir de cette crise non mais
c'était un secret de polichinelle que
cette deuxième formulation du Rip serait
rotoquée par le Conseil constitutionnel
parce que l'été écrit par des militants
pas par des juristes et le Conseil
constitutionnel il juge en droit moi je
pense qu'il y a un dévoiement voyez du
Rip tous ceux qui sont attachés je le
suis moi attachés au référendum je pense
que la crise démocratique que nous
traversons de la démocratie aussi
représentative devrait nous amener à une
pratique référendaire plus fréquente on
peut pas élire un président tous les 5
ans et ne rien faire pratiquement en 5
ans quand je parle de dévoiement
qu'est-ce que je veux dire je pense que
le rip a été fait pour faire la loi
faire la loi quand le Parlement par
exemple
c'était soit opposé ou n'avait pas mis
dans son ordre du jour un sujet
particulier faire la loi mais pas pour
défaire la loi et moi je pense que le
processus démocratique qu'a subi le cas
parcouru le texte sur les retraites est
un vrai parcours conforme à nos
institutions enfin le Sénat nous l'avons
voté une première fois en première
lecture nous l'avons ratifié en
commission mixte parité avec les députés
revotez ensuite donc ça correspond à nos
institutions de la Cinquième République
vous dites vous dites finalement à la
gauche et à tous les opposants à la
réforme des retraites que le cheminement
démocratique selon les mots du
gouvernement et désormais terminé et
qu'il faut passer à autre chose mais je
dis l'intersyndical quand on voit les
violences je dis que il faut savoir
terminer une grève parce qu'on voit bien
que c'est en train de dégénérer
de mobilisation donc je pense qu'à
chaque fois qu'il y a une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation il y a des
risques qui sont des risques de violence
d'hyper violence et c'est très
responsabilité il faut que chacun
l'assume
parce qu'il y a des violences j'ai non
j'ai quand même noté que il y a une
fissure dans la terre syndicale on voit
bien que la CFDT la CFC et d'autres
commencent à se dire si le gouvernement
du temps la main nous la prendrons on
voit bien que les jusqu'au boutistices
sont du côté de la CGT les syndicats
réformistes entrent dans une nouvelle
salle dans une nouvelle phase on l'a
très bien senti aux dernières
déclarations il y a quelques jours
notamment du leader de la saleté
le 6 juin vous vous dites il faut pas
faire cette mobilisation de ces gens
c'est le responsabilité non
un vrai sujet on a un vrai sujet la loi
anti-casseurs anti Black Blocs c'est
votre serviteur c'est nous qui l'avions
voté d'ailleurs contre le gouvernement à
l'époque au Sénat simplement il y a de
problème il y a un problème avant et un
problème après avant on avait prévu dans
ce texte à l'article 3 j'avais prévu un
dispositif qui permette un peu comme les
hooligans qui sont interdits de pénétrer
dans des stades quand ils ont été
convaincus de violence j'avais prévu
dans l'article 3 un mécanisme qui
permettait au préfet d'interdire à des
gens dangereux de manifester avec des
conditions préventivement préventivement
très restrictive mais qui a été jugé ont
été constitutionnellement c'est pas mon
texte qui était jugé anticonstitutionnel
c'est le texte qui avait été voté par
les députés à la demande de Christophe
Castaner moi j'avais prévu des
conditions très resserrées par exemple
que le préfet pouvant interdire
simplement pour la durée d'une
manifestation aux abords et dans la
manifestation et sous l'impulsion de
Monsieur Castaner les députés avaient
voté quelque chose de beaucoup plus
large sur tout le territoire national
donc vous dites-moi et donc le Conseil
constitutionnel laissez-moi terminer
pardon à juger que c'était dix
proportionné donc moi je pense que il y
a un trou dans la raquette il y a une
guérilla que nous mène les cagoule noir
et il faut s'y adapter c'est des
techniques parabilitaires donc le
bouclier que que constitue que doit
constituer la loi doit être plus ferme
ça c'est avant mais il y a un problème
aussi après je m'explique je prends
seulement un exemple
les myfastations la Concorde la nuit du
16 août 17 mars
293 ou 14 arrestations là-dessus il y
aura 97% de classement sans suite c'est
à dire aucune suite judiciaire aucune
sanction mais ça c'est un encouragement
à aller de l'avant donc on voit bien que
préventivement
vous dites laxisme judiciaire les
défenseurs des droits dit que il y a un
abus de
je dis laxisme judiciaire notamment
l'accusez j'accuse de ne pas faire leur
travail en fait non je n'accuse pas les
juges de ne pas faire le travail
j'accuse de Syndicat de la magistrature
qui a beaucoup d'adhérents dans le corps
des magistrats d'être totalement
politisés quand le Syndicat de la
magistrature publie un communiqué avec
le titre justement au mois de mars que
l'autorité judiciaire ne peut pas être
au service de la répression sociale
quelle répression sociale quand le même
syndicat la magistrature envoie ses
adhérents quelques jours avant le
l'opération Un bouchou à Mayotte que on
doit pas être non plus au service de la
violation des droits humains et que
comme par hasard son ancienne
vice-présidente détourne pour moi c'est
un détournement quand elle a arrêté
justement le l'acte préfectoral en
essayant de s'appuyer sur la
détournement de comment dire d'une voie
de fait c'est un détournement pourquoi
parce qu'elle dit détournement enfin
voie de fait dans la mesure où il y a
violation du droit de propriété mais ces
gens-là qui dans les bidonvilles ils
n'ont pas de droites propriétés et
j'espère que la Cour d'appel ils
remettra bon endroit donc là vous mettez
vous mettez en jeu
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire première
proposition reprendre le texte que
j'avais proposé équilibré et je pense
qu'il passera les mailles du Conseil
constitutionnel pour appliquer
vous appelez le ministre de le ministre
de l'Intérieur a finalement travaillé
avec vous pour c'est une erreur du
gouvernement ils ont dénaturé mon texte
ils se sont fait censurer bien première
chose et je pense là aussi alors on est
sur la justice qu'il faut des politiser
la justice comment qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire parce que on parle d'un syndicats
enlever le droit au jeu d'être syndiqué
ça on peut en discuter
pour des raisons professionnelles oui
mais pour une politisation la justice
doit être au-dessus de tout soupçon je
vais reprendre ma démonstration
souvenez-vous de l'affaire du mur des
cons
préventive basée sur absolument rien des
procès-verbaux qui étaient remplis à la
va-vite voire même de façon automatique
il y a quand même aussi des
interrogations bien sûr il y a la
question des nullités il faut que la
judiciarisation dans ces cas-là soit
plus précise il faut des moyens il faut
un cerdant de choses il y a aussi la
question de la simplification parce que
c'est tellement compliqué désormais que
tout est nul est-ce que vous croyez
normal que sur près de 300 arestations
97%, il y a aucune condamnation c'est
des classements sans suite les Français
sont choqués alors que on voit bien des
gens qui viennent pour tuer du flic
est-ce qu'on peut continuer comme ça
pour que demain vous voyez qu'il y a un
jeu policier qui était grièvement blessé
il va emporter à vie des stigmates et
alors on fait rien on ne bouge pas
encore une fois le mur des cons et la
personne responsable de cette faute
magistrale j'utilise lequel qualificatif
à bon escient elle est promue ensuite
vous trouvez ça normal Julien Lecuyer
sur les Black Blocs sur les moyens on
dirait d'y répondre est-ce que vous vous
avez une proposition pour justement
lutter contre cette
proposition mon texte déjà a été adopté
première chose il a été dénaturé je vous
parlais de l'article 3 je pense qu'il
faut revenir sur cet article 3 il faut
que le Conseil constitutionnel puisse si
j'ose dire ne pas le censurer pour qu'il
ne soit pas censuré il faut être mesuré
je veux dire que on est dans un état de
droit c'est pour ça que j'avais demandé
moi ce que l'arrêté préfectorale
concerne un périmètre dans l'espace très
précis concerne dans le temps là encore
un périmètre comment vous très restreint
à la seule durée de la manifestation
vous avez jugé les
Emmanuel Macron et Elizabeth borne ont
attaqué mercredi Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça
c'est un lien puisque eux-mêmes on
parlait du fait de des propos de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui semblait
justifier ou en tout cas attaquer les
les policiers mais aussi qui feraient
selon le président de la République la
courte échelle au rassemblement national
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord sur ce
diagnostic
moi je pense que l'extrême gauche
altération sanitaire en France leur
objectif en réalité ça n'est pas
d'abattre la réforme des retraites c'est
d'abattre la Cinquième République vous
avez vu comme moi les images à
l'Assemblée nationale de la lecture du
texte sur les retraites vous avez vu
cette violence verbale la violence
verbale c'est l'antichambre de la
violence tout court voilà donc il y a
une forme de complicité ça ne se lit moi
j'ai vécu aussi Notre Dame des Landes je
sais ce qui s'est passé
soulèvement de la terre c'est né où
c'est né à Notre Dame Blanche la photo
originale est bien celle d'Édouard
Philippe et Emmanuel Macron puisque pour
les beaux yeux de Monsieur Hulot et fait
ma ministre à l'époque de
l'environnement on a sacrifié un projet
qui était un projet qui politiquement de
droite de gauche du centre et d'ailleurs
étaient portés par tous les responsables
avec 179 décisions de justice positive
favorables à ce grand aéroport et on a
cédé à la violence on a donné un permis
de casser c'est tout donc là encore la
politique doit être une politique
cohérente on peut pas donner un jour
raison au casseurs aux ultra-violents à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et demain leur
donner tort et les combattre à Sainte
Soline la politique c'est la cohérence
c'est ce qui manque d'ailleurs Aymen
Macron le en même temps c'est par
définition le double langage donc
l'incohérence
pour la suite pour les opposants et
notamment la proposition de loi de lot
qui serait 18 juin Julien oui puisqu'on
parle de cohérence il y en a un qui dès
qui qui sont réclame c'est Aurélien
Pradier qui a annoncé qu'il votera la
proposition loi portée par le groupe lot
le 8 juin qui vise à abroger la réforme
des retraites est-ce qu'il va trop loin
au lien Pradier quand il parle de ça peu
importe je veux plus commenter ce que
dit ce que fait ce député l'air
simplement ce que je dis moi pour
prendre un peu de recul et de hauteur
sur cette proposition de loi liotte
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans les 10 ans
c'est pas 150 milliards de déficits
qu'on va avoir en réalité on le voit
bien maintenant aussi bien sur la
croissance sur le taux de productivité
sur toutes ces hypothèses qui fondent ce
calcul de 150 milliards de déficits sur
les régimes de retraite en disant on
sera plus près de 200 milliards donc la
proposition liotte qu'est-ce qui est dit
à nos concitoyens qu'on fait rien
consacrifie le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités qu'on sacrifie les jeunes
demain puisque toujours plus de
retraités et toujours moins d'actifs de
cotisants qu'est-ce qu'on fait
exactement ça résout ça les problèmes de
la France et Madame Le Pen dont je vois
qu'elle vient déposer une PPL ou elle
revient à la fois sur la réforme de 2010
les 62 ans et sur la réforme de droite
donc et la réforme de gauche la réforme
Touraine en matière d’animité elle ruine
la France elle ruine le retraitée elle
ruine la jeunesse et elle encourage
immigration incohérence attendez
incohérent juste pardonnez-moi relevons
cette chose là je parlais de cohérence
d'incohérence d'Emmanuel Macron
incohérence de Madame Le Pen vous ne
pouvez pas si j'ose dire restin de
travail alors que on est à des pays qui
parlent plutôt en retraite il nous
manque des seniors dans l'emploi et ne
pas vouloir l'immigration évidemment
vous souvenez des déclarations à
l'époque de celui qui s'occupait
monsieur delvoy au commissaire retraite
il dit fraise 50 millions d'immigrés en
plus si on fait rien en 19 en 2050
non mais je parler de cohérence est-ce
qu'on peut être député les républicains
et voter un texte qui abroge la réforme
des retraites que vous défendez la
liberté il y a la liberté moi je pense
que c'est pas je ne pense je pense que
ça n'est pas cohérent je pense que c'est
d'autant moins cohérent que la même
personne dont vous me parlez quand on a
eu cette élection cette campagne pour la
présidence de LR soutenait une retraite
à 67 ans puisqu'il soutenait 45 à nuité
45 à nuité alors que la moyenne d'entrée
sur le marché du travail c'est plus de
22 ans 22 ans plus 45 à nuité égale
combien 67 ans
il faut répondre il faut répondre
sur le parti sur les républicains vous
rejoignez en fait ce que disait eriki
les vos mots sur se rejoignent ce qui
nous a abîmé c'est la dispersion dit-il
nous sommes apparus incohérents
maintenant il faut remonter la pente
mais alors justement comment remonter
cette cette pente il y a il y a pas 36
solutions
qu'est-ce qui aimante dans la vie
politique la tension de nos compatriotes
c'est le pouvoir parce que le pouvoir
fascine souvent quand on a le pouvoir on
est puissant on attire on n'a pas le
pouvoir on est loin du pouvoir l'autre
puissance d'attraction ce sont les idées
et l'utilité parce qu'il faut qu'on soit
utile la républicains c'est pas écrit
c'est écrit nulle part dans le marbre
qu'on doit exister à perpétuité
l'utilité qu'on doit avoir c'est
l'utilité pour nos idées on doit être
disruptif on doit proposer dans le débat
public quelque chose de nouveau or moi
je pense que le monde la France on est
arrivé à un bout de cycle le manque qui
est dangereux une mondialisation qui se
reconfigure sur des blocs idéologiques
continentaux la France la fête est finie
il y a plus d'argent magique j'ai
observé que le taux d'emprunt pour les
OAP les emprunts d'État plus de 3,2% au
mois de mars magique monsieur ça fait 20
ans 30 ans qu'on entend parler de cette
formule ce que je propose c'est que nous
n'aurons d'avenir ça bien il va y avoir
des étages généraux nous n'aurons
d'avenir que si hache sur chaque point
nous avons des idées de rupture on a ils
n'ont pas traité les conséquences
j'entendais encore sur le lycée
professionnel c'est toujours plus
d'argent public
Emmanuel Macron confond la réforme et la
dépense publique il les associe c'est ce
qu'on fait remarquer depuis 30 ans ou 40
ans et bien nous je pense que je vous
parlais de la sécurité la question de la
sécurité aujourd'hui en France c'est pas
une question de moyens si il faut
construire plus de place de prison mais
c'est une question de réponse pénale
bien sûr il faut plus de magistrats mais
c'est ça sert à rien d'avoir plus de
magistrats s'il y a du laxisme
judiciaire autre l'hôpital là encore on
déverse des milliards mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on donnera à nos soignants
le sens de ce qu'ils font la quête du
sens de leur métier c'est en
débutocratissant l’hôpital en changeant
la gouvernance en la mettant du côté des
soignants plutôt que du côté de la
bureaucratie pareil pour l'école
s'en prend au privé privé ça marche
alors laissons privés vivre parce qu'il
y a d'ailleurs il le comprend si bien
que ses enfants sont à l'école
alsacienne qui est une école privée une
des plus chères voyez Tartuffe Tartuffe
bon c'est voyez à chaque fois on doit
être et pour l'école publique nous avons
proposé nous avons voté un texte au
Sénat que on crée des écoles publiques
autonome gratuite pour que on est
comment dire nouvelle pédagogies et on
verra bien vous vous comptez aussi faire
preuve de Dios disruption absolument
absolument sur l'immigration c'est bien
pour ça que le gouvernement craignait
l'examen du texte notamment au Sénat
qu'il y a renoncé parce que ils ont pas
renoncé parce que nous on serait divisés
on n'est pas du tout divisé avec les
députés pour preuve on déposera
prochainement un texte de loi quand les
prochaines semaines dans les prochaines
semaines mais on devait
ce que je veux dire c'est que je prends
cet exemple là à quoi ça sert de un
texte migratoire si les pompes
aspirantes tournent toujours à fond si
vous en rajoutez le fameux article 3
l'article 4 du texte de Monsieur
Darmanin c'était la régularisation
massive voilà des sans-papiers non et je
pense aussi exactement ni Olivier du
socle non on parle de plusieurs milliers
de de personnes mais je vous dis
regardez ce qui se passe à Mayotte
regardez ce qui se passait à Mayotte à
Mayotte ou désormais c'est le cas où
migratoire 50% de la population ce sont
des étrangers 50% de ces étrangers sont
des irréguliers et Marine Le Pen le a
fait 59% son père il y a 20 ans n'avait
fait que
11,7%, ce que vous dites que c'est que
ce qui se passe à Mayotte finalement le
chaos migratoire que vous exposez bien
sûr ça pourrait être la France dans
quelques années pas dans le même
proportion aujourd'hui bien sûr mais
j'ai pris Mayotte on aurait pu prendre
d'autres grands pays européens on aurait
pu prendre la Suède le Danemark regardez
le Danemark le Danemark pourtant ce sont
des sociaux-démocrates un tour de vis
sans précédent disruptif la rupture eux
ils ont fait la rupture la rupture que
je demande vois sur l'immigration et
bien eux ils l'ont fait et la rupture
sur l'immigrés vous avez vu regardez ce
qu'on fait les le parti d'extrême droite
il a été réduit il faisait plus de 20 %
il y a quelques années à moins de 3 % la
Suède c'est l'inverse ils ont pas été
capable de maîtriser justement
l'immigration et du coup l'extrême
droite et aux portes du pouvoir au
gouvernement s'il ne suit pas votre
ligne sur l'immigration c'est ouvrir la
voie à Marine Le Pen dans les prochaines
vidéos
elle doit mettre dans dans
cierges tous les jours gouvernement
persiste
il faudra un référendum sur la question
j'avais proposé vous voyez j'avais
travaillé sur les 100 jours pour Valérie
Pécresse je pourrais vous les fournir
c'est un document que vous pourrez
facilement travailler et j'avais proposé
bien sûr une réforme constitutionnelle
pourquoi là encore parce qu'on tombe
dans le gouvernement juge et que il
faudra autoriser modifier l'article 11
de la Constitution pour permettre au
peuple français de se prononcer et donc
sur les questions migratoires et ce que
dit un référendum le Conseil
constitutionnel ne peut pas en juger
donc ce sera enfin la souveraineté
populaire et ça ne sera pas le
gouvernement des juges parce que cette
question c'est une question qui
désormais peut menacer notre cohérence
notre cohésion sociale il faut choisir
entre ouvrir les Français et maintenir
un haut niveau de protection sociale il
faut choisir l'un ou l'autre je choisis
un modèle français qui va falloir
réinventer c'est ce que LR doit faire
réinventer un système à bout de souffle
être disruptif être en rupture par
rapport à ce qui a été fait avant à ce
que nous-mêmes nous avons fait à ce que
des gouvernements LR des présidents de
République et ça Nicolas Sarkozy ou
d'autres ont fait mais est-ce que le
meilleur moyen de mettre en oeuvre vos
idées de les faire entendre des
appliquer rapidement c'est pas de passer
dans les prochains mois un accord de
gouvernement
mais la politique je disais c'est des
idées
avec qui passait un accord avec le ML
Macron qui
donne satisfaction aux hadistes de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes ou celui qui
combat les mêmes indistes à Sainte
Soline est-ce que on doit passer un
accord avec Monsieur Macron qui nomme
monsieur Papon Diagne qui est
une sorte de walkie de Bontin
dans chic etc ou avec le même Macron qui
avait nommé d'ailleurs monsieur Blanquer
qui était assez intransigeant sur la
laïcité avec qui passer un accord je
pense que c'est les idées qui commandent
la politique Emmanuel moi je ne suis pas
dans un
beaucoup de choses qui vont dans votre
sens est-ce que si c'est avec le
Emmanuel Macron qui va t'en quand même
la main sur plusieurs sujets Emmanuel
Macron
regardez sur la fraude sociale qu'il va
présenter dans les procédures et sur la
réforme des retraites nous l'avons voté
ce qui veut dire que il y a un chemin
possible que le Sénat pratique depuis
des années textes par texte quand un
texte est bon moi je ne réagis pas
encore faisable n'est pas Emmanuel
Macron bah vous seul c'est l'intérêt
national du pays et des Français de vos
rangs mon souhait c'est une politique de
redressement de la France et aujourd'hui
je ne vois pas le premier ministre je me
renvoie pas c'est pas le problème c'est
les idées c'est les conditions la
dépense publique pour nous le maire se
promène de plein d'eau en plateau pour
dire STOP un temps quoi qu'il en coûte
on vient de nous transmettre un document
important sur la stabilité que Bruxelles
demande la prévision de dépenses
publiques 2027 c'est plus 30 milliards
30 milliards de plus de dépenses
publiques que ce que l'on nous disait
dans le projet de programmation des
finances publiques il y a seulement cinq
mois donc
il continue au moment où justement les
taux s'envolent ou le service de la
dette coûte de plus en plus cher et là
maintenant
ce goulet d’étranglement on arrive à son
terme et ça menace donc
regardez c'est ta fiche ça n'a rien
bouleversé c'est simplement un
avertissement c'est un coup de semence
c'est tout mais derrière Fitch il peut y
avoir beaucoup plus grave que cela
beaucoup plus grave quand on a une dette
de 3000 milliards le relèvement des taux
encore plus justement de services de la
dette qui va nous coûter beaucoup plus
cher et ce qu'on doit dépenser par
exemple pour la transition écologique ce
qu'on doit dépenser pour un certain
nombre d'investissements d'avenir on
n'aura pas cet argent cet argent devra
simplement le dépenser pour les marchés
financiers merci Bruno Retailleau merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin Julien regardait Une de La Voix du
Nord les stars s'invite au stade Pierre
Mauroy
la présence de Stromae en juin on suivra
tout ça dans la micro merci
[Rires]